yes it's not it's not that bad is it I
mean you you've been there what is it a
good atmosphere in the room yeah I mean
you can drink which is fun it's like
here it's the best one to be at yes
probably the worst one to host because
they're all drunk yeah I know and then I
feel bad for everyone that has to get up
yes no one's paying anything as the
night goes on people know they've lost
yeah and then a roomful of losers yeah
you gotta calm down I have to say shut
up yeah you came over to well you do not
remember that there's no way
the researcher told me about on it in my
defense I was loads of people coming
over and it was crazy I think by
yourself and I came over
[Applause]
know anyone there so I know it was
overwhelming we were standing with the
office yeah I'm just one like first goal
of it was crazy and they loved the show
as everyone loved I didn't realize how
fat and sweaty I was until I saw the
pictures
[Music]
you